l'autre chiffre du jour et est en faveur
de l'écologie il s'agit du marathon
caritatif vie event qui a récolté plus
de 10 millions d'euros vous voyez de
chiffres exacts qui s'affiche alors le
vainement à durer tout le week-end à
montpellier 57 stars du jeu vidéo se
sont affrontés pendant plus de cinquante
heures une cagnotte avait été ouverte
pour l'occasion mais ces dons permettent
de soutenir plusieurs associations
caritatives
le blast heavy médor counter strike se
tiendra à paris alors ce message
opportuniste n'a pas du tout plu à la
communauté twitch qui a répondu en
direct en insultant le président non
macro à tweeté sérieux oh non je m'en
bats les bonjour je m'appelle et
1024 oui parce que rien en fait j'ai
l'impression d'être utilisés pour lui
pour essayer de gratter des trucs auprès
des jeunes et ça me casse les je suis
féministe
et là ça suffit
ça suffit
ces petits arrangements avec nos
consciences chrome que quand on est là à
revendiquer parfois la fin du patriarcat
et quand on m'envoie un pluie les
patriat puce plus il est en voilà un
alors on me dit que fabrice et là
fabrice mais attendez vous
fabrice
lui est en train de bricoler ballan
fabrice vous n'êtes pas tenté ce que
vous êtes en train de faire quoi fabrice
la dsi vous êtes vous rangé
l'a déjà je ne peux pas vous en vouloir
qui ronge la cuisine boudissa
naturellement c'est ce que j'ai dans
cette émission plus on va se dire ah ben
oui d'accord non mais pas lui non non
non stop alors on n'a pas tout compris
alors je sais pas mais le monsieur à
côté ne comprend pas non plus
ici il faut pas le jeu bouche parce que
sinon ça va se voir mais ya pas de paris
qui est en chantier
c'est compliqué
là
[Musique]
key
bayrou
et
[Musique]
sa danse
l'eau
[Musique]
dévoile les premières images du film la
petite sirène avec dans le rôle
principal la chanteuse à libé comme à
l'annonce du casting les critiques
fusent car ariel n'est pas blanche et
rouge comme dans le dessin animé de 1989
mais noir et elle a des dreadlocks
dans un océan de commentaires parfois
négatifs surnagent des réactions de
petites filles
émue en découvrant la bande annonce
[Applaudissements]
je me sens très bien c'est qu'il ya un
truc et je me sens très bien je te jette
et pas cher je te jure c'est vrai non
c'est pas
nul qu'est ce que tu vois quand tu te
vois qu'est ce qu'elle voit elle
elle voit qu'elle a bien fait que
s'allonger
pour la gravité car à 48 ans on préfère
maintenant et c'est vrai il n'ya plus
que comme ça qu'on peut supporter parce
que l'attraction terrestre dans le bon
sens voilà
l'excusé
basculeront satin mis pas si je te
laisse deux minutes pas du tout aller
chercher mon portable dans la voiture et
j'arrive
[Musique]
n'ont pas
bougé son bassin c'est quelque chose de
toujours très érotique chez les femmes
c'est ce qui permet d'attendre leur
astre est donc dans l'espace social
bouger son bassin s'est vu comme une
provocation
et là les femmes viennent parquet au
moment de manifestations féministes pour
montrer que l se réapproprient leur
corps et qu'elles peuvent bouger leur
bassin sans être dans une posture qui
est immédiatement sexuelle ou sexualisé
[Musique]
prenez ce groupe d'amis et leur concours
de certes pas fait pour à tour ils
tentent leur chance ont créé à la main
sur un grand tableau noir comme dans
toute compétition il y avait moins doués
ceux qui ont failli réussir
et les mauvais perdant
jusqu'à ce que miracle un participants
réaliseront ultime
[Applaudissements]